irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit der
quantenphysik da gibt es schrödingers
katze die zugleich tot und lebendig ist
oder das doppel spalt experiment bei dem
teilchen als wellen durch zwei schlitze
gleichzeitig fliegen
es ist eine große tragische geschichte
für die physik aber auch für einen mann
der eigentlich den nobelpreis verdient
hätte wegen dieser geschichte trat die
quantentheorie wahrscheinlich 70 jahre
lang auf der stelle und ein mann wurde
gebrochen von seinem eigenen doktorvater
dem entwickler der ersten atombombe
robert oppenheimer
doch jetzt scheint die physik diesen
alten skandal aufzuarbeiten und das
ändert alles wir stehen für einen
quantensprung in der theorie der
quantenmechanik klicks und salz in
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
hey leute ich bin total begeistert unser
podcast ist in den top ten science
podcast in deutschland ich bin total
euphorisch dass euch die machart so gut
gefällt die neue bauer also für
unterwegs zum einschlafen und alles
mögliche hierunter me ist der link zum
podcast mit den extra infos und
erläuterung die ich jetzt immer frei von
der leber weg in den podcast einfließen
lassen sie links spotify und apple
podcast sind auch in der video
beschreibung hier unter dem video und im
ersten kommentar das ist ein wirklicher
umbruch in der physik einem jahr tot
geglaubte theorie wird langsam wieder
zum leben erweckt es geht um den
verschmähten physiker louis begley er
hatte in den zwanziger jahren des
letzten jahrhunderts eine idee die die
seltsamen ereignisse der quantenphysik
viel besser erklären konnte denn in
dieser teilchenphysik verhalten sich
teilchen sowie wählen und dann eben doch
nicht auf der solvay konferenz auf der
fünften stellte er 19 27 seine idee vor
teilchen sind eben nicht teilchen und
wählen zugleich sondern teilchen deren
bewegungsrichtung und geschwindigkeit
aber durch eine wellenfunktion
beschrieben wird
wir haben ja schon oft über dieses
paradoxon berichtet und ist als gegeben
angenommen
die idee von den boni spielte bis vor
kurzem eben keine rolle
er wurde auf der fünften sommerkonferenz
so in die mangel genommen dass er seine
idee wieder frustriert aufgabe und das
sollte sich noch ein zweiter
wiederholen ja das ist verrückt aber
auch traurig für die wissenschaft aber
kaum für den polit er hatte nämlich den
welle teilchen dualismus von elektronen
überhaupt entdeckt und erhielt nur 27
den nobelpreis für physik
er ist übrigens auch der urvater des
cern in genf des kernforschungszentrums
in dem mit dem large hadron collider der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
gebaut wurden 149 schlug in einem papier
den bau vor aber noch ein weiterer
physiker wurde wegen dieser theorie von
den etablierten physik forschen sogar
geächtet es war david bowie mehr als 20
jahre später entdeckte er den jazz
theorie wieder und er bewies dass die
bank ließ theorie genau so gut
funktionierte wie die klassischen
konnten theorie die theorie bekam mit
diesen belegt den namen de poli home
theorie dbb und boden traf es noch
härter sein doktorvater der erfinder und
konstrukteur der ersten atombombe robert
oppenheimer verstieg sich zu einer
ziemlich abschätzigen aussage wir halten
dies für jugendlichen die via zionismus
wenn wir bogen nicht widerlegen können
dann müssen wir zustimmen ihn zu
ignorieren
das muss man schon schäbig nennen und
vor allem unwissenschaftlich was für
eine arroganz einstein war sich nicht
ganz so sicher
zum einen schrieb er in einem brief an
den physiker und ebenfalls
nobelpreisträger max born hast du
gesehen dass der boden wie übrigens vor
25 jahren schon weh problem glaubt dass
er die quantentheorie deterministisch
umdeuten kann der weg schalten mir zu
billig denn das ist der clou von den
profis theorie die bahn jetzt sogar noch
weiter beleben konnte ereignisse lassen
sich vorhersagen der ort an dem an
teilchen hinter dem doppelstart auftritt
ist laut de broglie und bohm
vorhersehbaren der weg dorthin
unterliegt zwar der wellenfunktion aber
ausgehend von der vorherigen
geschwindigkeit und richtung weiß man
schon vorher wo das teilchen auf treffen
wird also kein journalismus keine
teilchen die gleichzeitig wählen sind
deshalb war ein stein auf der anderen
seite auch einen bogen fan er sei der
einzige der über die konten mechanik
hinaus kommen könnte sagte wohl ein
stein aber auch wie dem publikum seine
überlegungen aufgrund der ablehnenden
haltung gegenüber wieder auf
und jetzt weist seine und den mobiles
theorie wahrscheinlich ein weg der die
verbindung von quantenphysik und
relativitätstheorie ermöglicht 70 jahre
später nur wegen ein paar stuhr köpfen
oder sogar 100 jahre nach de broglie die
alten weißen männer sind wirklich ein
problem und habe in diesem fall sogar
dafür gesorgt dass die theoretische
physik auf der stelle trat und damit
meine ich nicht generell alter weise
männer ist dass ich bin ja auch einer
sondern eine verbitterte geisteshaltung
die sich gegen zwangsläufige
veränderungen sträubt das haben wir ja
auch bei der energiewende oder der
elektromobilität da wird dann lieber
gelogen und betrogen sie diese betrug
software statt im interesse der
menschheit zu handeln die alten weiß
männer der physik haben es hier also so
richtig versammelt denn wenn man
verstehen will was in der quantenphysik
auf mikroskopischer ebene passiert also
bei den wirklichen ganz kleinen teilchen
dann landet man bei der progen theorie
denn das ist die einzige theorie die das
vernünftig und logisch erklären kann
denn das auf mikroskopischer ebene dinge
passieren die unmöglich sind eben das
teilchen auch wählen sind kann ja sein
aber wenn es doch ein besseres modell
gibt was das alles viel besser und vor
allem logischer erklärt und sich dabei
in widersprüche zu verwickeln ja dann
ist das wohl ein modell das man sich mal
genauer ansehen sollte es ist doch viel
logischer das teilchen sich nach
wellenfunktion verteilen als dass die
welle und teilchen gleichzeitig sind
denn auch wenn das muster hinter dem
doppel spalt wellenartig ist treffen die
teilchen doch an bestimmten orten auf
doch und das macht die bisherige
klassische bekannten mechanik so
unlogisch die wellenfunktion
funktioniert nicht so richtig für ein
teilchen passt es noch die welle läuft
im dreidimensionalen raum für zwei
teilchen läuft sie aber im sechs themen
sozialer raum nur so stimmt sie dann das
zweite teilchen hat der funktion drei
weitere dimensionen hinzugefügt und das
passiert bei jedem weiteren teilchen das
heißt jedes zeitigen 53 neue dimensionen
hinzu die probleme löste das elegant mit
teilchen die einer wellenfunktion folgen
sprich die teilchen treffen beim doppel
spielt experiment nicht mehr an
irgendeinem ort auf sondern der ist
durch richtung und geschwindigkeit des
teilchens und durch die wellenfunktion
definiert einsteins gott würfelt nicht
macht zumindest in diesem fall wieder
sinn und noch etwas spricht für die dbb
de
die bäume um theorie in der klassischen
quantenmechanik gibt es keine zeit es
fällt deshalb extrem schwer die dauer
von ereignissen zu berechnen nicht so
bei der db und es gibt noch zahlreiche
fälle bei denen die db die idee bullien
theorie einfach besser und einfacher ist
jetzt steht aber die nächste
herausforderung an und vielleicht ist da
auch die lange verschmähte dbb die
lösung die vereinigung der
relativitätstheorie meter quantenphysik
hintergrund raum und zeit werden
gekrümmt gravitation ist nichts anderes
als ein relativistische effekt wir
werden aufgrund der phänomene auf die
erde gezogen die die relativitätstheorie
erklärt und vielleicht ist es schon dem
einen oder anderen aufgefallen
in der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
ist ein paradoxer kreislauf enthalten
massen ziehen licht an
da liegt aber nicht beschleunigt werden
kann müssen sich raum und zeit krümmen
sprich der raum wird zusammengedrückt
und die zeit verläuft langsamer die raum
krümmung verursacht aber die gravitation
die dafür verantwortlich ist dass das
licht angezogen wird
ursache und wirkung sind hier genau das
gleiche das ist schon ziemlich verrückt
also was ist der grund dafür und wo ist
des rätsels lösung verborgen ist es die
stringtheorie oder die schleifen
quantengravitation eines ist jedenfalls
spannend die quantenphysik heißt ja so
weil dort nichts mehr kontinuierlich
verläuft sondern in kleinen quanten
kleinen schritten
wendet man jetzt die übliche
quantenphysik auf die
relativitätstheorie an dann kommt dabei
die sogenannte wiener de wit gleichung
heraus sie hat allerdings bisher
unüberwindbare mathematische menge bei
der schleifen gravitation wird sie
modifiziert und hat ein super spannendes
ergebnis raum und zeit sind nicht mehr
kontinuierlich sondern qualifiziert
haben also eine körnige struktur was
natürlich wieder etwas an teilchen
erinnert und jetzt kommt wieder die dbb
theorie ins spiel und hier gibt es ein
absolut spektakuläres ergebnis bzw einen
hinweis darauf den der physiker bord
studie in spektrum beschreibt denn es
könnte die branche variante der villa de
wit gleichung ohne dunkle energie einen
expandierenden kosmos enthalten moment
what das wäre ein
absolut unglaubliches ergebnis so mal
eben nebenbei erklärt die den boliden
theorie die dunkle energie oder eben
warum sie zur erklärung der
beschleunigten ausdehnung des weltalls
gar nicht benötigt wird wahnsinn
damit hätte boom tatsächlich den
nobelpreis verdient denn das ist absolut
bahnbrechend es hat ihn aber ein ganz
anderes schicksal ereilt in der
amerikanischen mccarthy ära der
kommunistenverfolgung wurde ihm der pass
abgenommen und er musste flüchten aus
den usa
seine arbeit wurde eben von robert
oppenheimer und das vollkommen und
argumente verunglimpft und auch andere
physiker stieß ins selbe horn und das
ohne grundlage bis in die 90er jahre
wurden arbeiten zur komischen mechanik
nicht anerkannt und als
unwissenschaftlich abgelehnt und dann
spielt eben auch noch seine nähe zur
esoterik übel mit erhielt engen kontakt
zum indischen guru jesu christi
frustriert starb er 1992 in london
die wiederentdeckung seiner theorie
konnte er nicht mehr miterleben und
einen nobelpreis den hat er sowieso
nicht bekommen das ist tragisch und das
vor allem auch für die physik nur weil
ein paar physiker koryphäen zu stur
waren konnte sich eine theorie nicht
durchsetzen die die welt der teilchen
wahrscheinlich korrekt beschreibt ja
eine absolut unglaubliche geschichte
mehr dazu wie immer zumindest seit
dieser woche im podcast also mehr im
sinne von da werde ich mir erzählen
dafür
hier klicken und ansonsten bis dann ist
übrigens auch im ersten kommentar unter
dem video in der video beschreibung hier
unter mir
bis dann bleibt dran